this is like a therapy session patricia
bryant she's a creator
author entrepreneur with an incredible
story growing up
my mum should take us to offices to
clean the offices and we'll go to school
and she would say like just don't tell
anyone that you're working at five
o'clock in the morning
you just go to school in the morning and
act like everything was normal
there is pressure for influencers to
speak up on every topic
all the time bearing in mind that my
forte is
makeup and clothing and financed you
know to an extent but we
are not credible sources who know
everything
we just don't and i think it's really
important for us to say speaking up on
stuff that you know nothing about is
very very
dangerous i had a stalker for like three
years and it was someone who would like
just message me on all my platforms
constantly
send emails message family members so i
did a meet and greet an event
and then they messaged me like haha i
was at your meet and greet so i remember
feeling so anxious
you didn't see me you look so terrible
in person next time i'm gonna
do something
patricia bryant she's a creator author
entrepreneur
and a mother and she has a remarkable
inspiring story growing up on a
councillors day
having her dad deported when she was
just five years old
a nigerian mother that came to this
country doing cleaning jobs
at night which she took patricia along
to with her
and that mother became a property mogul
and patricia
she became a superstar in her own right
so it's no surprise that when i looked
at the comments section on a previous
podcast episode
a comment requesting patricia bright to
sit here with me and to be on this
podcast
had over a hundred upvotes and now i
know why
her attitude perspective ambition
self-belief resilience is incredible
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diver of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
yes we share one big similarity with our
childhoods
in the fact that we both had nigerian
mothers we do
we do yeah i didn't know that really no
i didn't actually well i still have
nigerian mother so
yeah yeah we both have nigerian mothers
and
um i believe both of our nigerian
mothers moved from nigeria to the uk
yeah um so they they were both born in
nigeria so they're
you know authentic roots are there but
you know tell me about the rest of your
childhood i only had one nigerian parent
i heard
okay you had two yeah i had both my mum
and dad
um growing up um but my dad was actually
deported
so he got deported when i was probably
like
six years old and i actually remember
the experience of his
deportation as being something very
traumatic
in hindsight as an adult i recognized
that but
growing up you know with an african mom
african dad
our culture was just a part of us on an
everyday basis
but also i was from south london as well
so i kind of grew up in battersea
and i came from a very diverse school
but i always went back to like a very
african home and um
yeah i think it really shaped me to who
i am today
in what ways i think it's that kind of
i'm going to say aggression there's
something about nigerians out of
all other people from say the diaspora
um
that i think means that we're quite
aggressive and very passionate let's not
say aggressive let's say passionate
we're intense we know what we want and
there's also a huge sense of
like pride as well that we can do
anything
and we're good and i feel very
privileged that i had a lot of that
you're great you'll do well you'll be
successful
don't worry about what's going on don't
don't see reality
as a definition of a limitation for
yourself
and i think that that's really made me
do a lot of things that
supposedly i shouldn't be able to do but
that kind of upbringing made me be like
no i can do it
it's fine it was always fine i watched
my mum do a lot of things
that would be considered impossible for
her
and she just did it with ease and chaos
in my
opinion now but somehow she kind of
achieved those things
and i would feel very privileged to kind
of grow up with that
sense of confidence instilled in me
which i think is really
cultural as a nigerian and i bet she
didn't complain either
oh there was no complaining she did she
just got on with it
like even when my dad was deported she
just got on with it and there were times
that
you know growing up my mom used to work
on the trains so she was one of the
train cleaners
and my sister's three and i'm five she'd
go out at night and leave us
because there was no one to like look
after her kids she'd go out she'll clean
she'll clean offices she'll take us to
offices to clean the offices
when we were younger and um she just did
it
and we'll go to school and she would say
like just don't tell anyone that you're
working at five o'clock in the morning
she obviously you're not going to go to
school
and tell people oh i've just been at
foxton's like
cleaning and helping my mom out you just
go to school in the morning and that
like everything was normal
um but no there wasn't any complaining
and she just kind of got on with it
and do you think you know you referred
to that as being that gave you kind of
confidence that you could do anything
but for me it sounds a lot like
because that immigrant story is so
connected with like survival
and that's why i talked about like she
didn't complain because it's like a lot
of complaint comes from
privilege almost doesn't it when you
feel like you have a choice
yeah but what's really also really
interesting is that some people still
feel lucky
the fact that she wasn't deported when
my dad was deported
she probably felt oh my god i'm so lucky
i got to kind of stay here
and um why would you complain when you
feel like you're in a better position
for yourself and your children in the
long term so
yeah she didn't have the privilege of
wanting to complain but i think she was
really like
happy to still be here though she had to
work hard
i think she knew that she had a lot of
opportunity
while being here and she'd be trained
and
she she became a nurse and then she
bought properties and then
she retired in her 40s like i love
england
in that it's kind of like the land of
opportunity for those who really want to
like you know work out what to do and
use it so i think she could see that
that was possible for her and you talked
about that that day when you were six
years old when you're
there's a knock on the door at nighttime
at night time it might have been
at night it might have been in the
middle of the day to be honest
what i do remember is like literally
about four
burley police officers officers kind of
walking in
um shouting like screaming like and
there's
me as a five-year-old my sister is a
three-year-old my mom in tears
and then literally dragging my dad out
of the house and it was like
your dad's gone like at that one moment
and we didn't see him again for seven
years
afterwards so it was like i at the time
i didn't i never processed it
it's only in the last year or two i've
processed
how kind of maybe traumatic that kind of
experience would have been for me as a
child
and i think it's also made me really be
fearful of loss which is why i work so
hard so that
things like that don't happen hopefully
to me and my family in the future
so in the last couple of years you've
had time to reflect on that and you i
guess you're saying
did you choose to reflect on that or go
through the journey of reflecting that
because you could see
things in your behavior that you thought
maybe that's connected
i didn't even recognize it i knew that
there was
like i work really hard like i'm really
intense and i'm always like let's just
keep going i'm always like that
and until i literally you know started
to have therapy as like
where does that come from and it was
that then got uncovered
in my therapy sessions that actually the
maybe one of the triggers for me
like working hard was because because of
that maybe fear of loss
um and obviously there's other aspects
as well i just
like hustling that's fun but there was
also maybe this thing here
that was one of my drivers that i've
actually used in a positive way but
it's also important to kind of reflect
on like dealing with things like that
and i think that i came from a place of
no it happened
that just happened it's fine on to the
next whereas like when you sit down and
talk about it you're like
oh that's that's not great yeah that's
50 years old
that's not a great situation yeah yeah
it must have taught you something about
something even if that lesson was wrong
that's where i think about it i'm like
that must have taught you something
about the nature of life because at five
years old you're learning what the world
means and what this means and that power
and your dad and your mum i must have
taught you some lesson about something
even if that lesson was wrong
right yeah exactly i mean i didn't even
realize that it could have been teaching
me something
like no idea but maybe that
stuff happened that's life you're not
really in control of anything
um but things like that can't stop you
yeah i mean yeah i think if my parents
were snatched out of my house i
definitely wouldn't feel safe
yeah i wouldn't feel safe you know
because that's
parents represent the foundation of like
safety in yeah
this is my house and these are my
parents and they just are yeah and then
one of those things is snatched out
it makes you i guess insecure about ever
feeling too safe to somebody
yeah but i think for me
maybe mine was that i can't rely
on the system or other people to
secure my safety maybe and so i kind of
i'm always trying to make sure i secure
myself
with the actions that i take because
those are the only things i'm in control
of
so i'm very much like i'll do it myself
i swear out myself
oh don't worry because you never know
what's going to happen there
and i i'm like that as a person does
that make you
paranoid about i guess
everything professionally no
it makes me really objective i'm like
i'm a pure realist
like something that's probably going to
go wrong at some point in time and
that's fine
like how are you going to handle that
like it's almost like i prepare for
something to
go wrong in a way this is like a therapy
session oh yeah i mean this is
this is pretty much what this podcast is
okay great yeah well no
i just find i i think when i started
this podcast i i am
i was anticipating to find these like
wild differences between everybody
but in fact i found the opposite which
is that fundamentally
um we're all very very similar right
when it relates to things like
insecurity and safety and childhood and
then
um obviously because in many respects
you've gone on to create a career for
yourself that is so
different from so many it would
sometimes you think well
what was the initial catalyst that
caused that person to be different what
was the like
the environment it's almost like a
cauldron what was the furnace they were
like
scolded in to make them then more
hardworking or obsessive or whatever and
um yeah i guess i mean having a nigerian
mother i
already know what that part is like you
could call it a cauldron
yeah yeah yeah yeah that work ethic
piece as well which um
is quite absent in this culture um and
that
you know what we talked about
complaining you referred to this as the
land of opportunity
yeah how does that make you feel when
you see people who
have lots of a much
more let's say financially privileged
start to life
um and they
don't fully understand the opportunity
the land of opportunity
so my first thought is like i roll
like oh there you go moaning or
complaining
but i also realized that there's so many
different types of privileges that
people have
that can actually provide them like a
long-term foundation
i think that if you do some people have
financial privilege but they have no
love they have no hope they have no
no one to tell them that they're good
whereas i mean
i've had the financial privileges but i
had a mom who was so loving and so
caring and
so encouraging that i was in a better
position just because i had that
so i don't want to ever tell someone
that you're privileged
because of xyz maybe in other areas they
didn't have the support that they needed
to actually um spur them on to be the
best version of themselves
um so i try not to be that judgmental
anymore because there's so many
different categorizations of privilege
and at some point you know you said your
mum she retrained herself
she became a nurse which is amazing yeah
um
and off you went to university i did
yeah i went off to university
mmu we have a similarity oh my gosh i
love that yeah
yeah i lost one lecture but i was there
for all three years but i just
dropped out yeah okay great and we have
that in common because i i was barely
there but i was i had a great social
life so it was enjoying
manchester is great it was great yeah
yeah no i went to
university after like leaving home and i
was so ready to like get out of my house
and get out of london and try something
new and then find myself
in like a new city i actually went in to
do
fashion marketing and to my parents
despair
because again as an african you don't do
fashion that's not
that's not a real course you do
accounting you do law
you do business you don't do fashion
marketing
um but i think i've always had this kind
of more creative
or creative streak as well as rebellious
streak as well
like i'm going to do what i want to do
um
but funny i kind of went there to do
fashion but changed my course to
accounting and finance
because i realized that there was no
financial hope
in fashion i was like oh i'm not going
to be broke when i leave university hell
no
so i changed purely on that on that
basis that you
purely on that basis i didn't love my
course and then when they were doing
internship opportunities they were
paying interns
8k a year 10k a year and like graduate
starting salaries
were like 8k and i was like i i'm not
rich enough to do this
no way and then i found out about
accounting and finance
and they they were like the banks that
had really good opportunities
and i was really good at the accounting
because we had a module
um in the fashion marketing and i would
i smashed it and i was like i'll do
accounting and finance
wow you said at this point that you were
your parents you know typical nigerian
parents my mom was the same when i
actually when i dropped out is when i
got help
but uh yeah because you know that's even
worse
rather you're doing something at
university just i feel like part of it's
just just so she can tell her friends or
something i was like
do you know what i mean it's just like
it's like i'm going to university so
that you
get a degree as being a good mother
my child is at university is what they
tell all the aunties
like it's very important yeah and at
that point your dad was
he was back in your life yes so by the
time
i was about 12 he came back
um so fundamentally they defined his
deportation as an illegal deportation
but we i remember going to the court
cases and my mom pleading with you know
social services and
lawyers and just people help us help us
get my our dad back like how do we do
this and then
we went to the court case and she was
like i don't know why this man was
deported
like gavel down bring him back i was
like that took seven years for you guys
to do that
but he got back and like he just started
again
worked as a security guard did all of
that kind of stuff and then ended up
working in the home office
for immigration which is so random
because
he was you know deported are you pissed
off about that
the fact that you lost your dad for
seven years for what
what sounds like it was a bit of a
mistake or just negligence
or at least a lack of empathy to take a
dad from their kids for what
yeah oh am i i'm not pissed off
maybe i haven't processed it enough to
be pissed off it just felt like
it is what it is and this is how it went
um
i felt more upset for my mum in that i
know
how difficult it was for her to like
have us and have responsibilities and
deal with like managing this court case
she managed it her entire self
she represented herself because she
didn't have money for like lawyers and
stuff
so she was under a lot of stress but she
did it and she did
other stuff as well so that was really
the main thing that kind of
upset me i'd say when did your dad come
back did you have a relationship with
him
it was weird it was so weird it's like
this is my dad
hi dad like how how do we have a
relationship with a man we haven't seen
for seven years
but um you know he was the kind of
what stoic african dad so i remember he
always gave me an envelope with money at
the beginning of term
like well done look after yourself okay
how's the weather
are you reading your books yes dad yes
dad okay good
like it was that kind of relationship
but i knew it was it was still
caring it was the way he kind of
communicated his
care for me which is that envelope of
cash and that's probably like a nigerian
generational cycle of like
male figures yeah just being a bit you
know a bit standoffish
about caring and when they ask you
certain questions
whether it's about the weather or your
studies how are
how is your studies going like that's
just they don't really know what else to
ask you
but them asking you that is is powerful
and my dad calls me every day is
hi how are you fine dad how'd the kids
find dad
okay bye like it just it's that checking
in which is really
i like it i think that's probably also
just a male
a male issue i think men typically
aren't as
um emotionally open so they don't build
that you know because vulnerability it's
well
connection seems to be built on
vulnerability and they seem to have a
bit of a guard up i
my dad is definitely exactly the same
like yeah the questions are so like
you know just say hi yes are you okay
yes okay goodbye
yeah yeah let me know if you're not okay
exactly
yeah um so mmu you go there you feel a
bit out of place
yeah quite out of place what do you mean
by that
because i'd never left like london and
i'd
like i had to make new friends and i
didn't know anyone and i wasn't
really good at it and i i couldn't
really find
my tribe very early on and i was on
a campus really far away i was on the
didsbury campus oh yeah like that was
the town
yeah out of town right and then there
was like the main campus for manchester
university
that everyone was at that's where i was
yeah
where i was like come on um and i
actually ended up like
moving out of my halls of residence
really and crashing
with a number of girls um in that main
campus
and i would move from room to room so
once one friend got annoyed of me after
two weeks
another friend would say i'd stay with
them for two weeks and then
i'd just go back and forth like a nomad
for a bit
and you you change course to accounting
yeah
in hindsight how important was it how
like pivotal was it
for you to have an understanding of
finance for everything that would then
come in your
in your career because i feel like i
feel like finance is such a neglected
topic for
for kids i wish someone had told me
about [ __ ] credit scores before i
smashed mine
okay so the moving role was pivotal for
my life like
it set me up on a completely different
trajectory that i
i wouldn't have even been aware of
because off the back of that role i
worked at
you know all the top four four companies
in the world in finance i worked at
merrill lynch and deloitte consulting
banks all of that stuff i would have
never done that
if i'd stayed in fashion when it came to
her from a
personal finance perspective didn't
prepare me at all
really not a clue i owed the tax man
money
i i i got my taxes wrong i had to pay
fines i had no clue what i was actually
doing
i had the degree i had the t1 great
you've passed
how do you actually apply financial
knowledge to
running your own business to your
everyday personal taxes like
i didn't have a clue spent the money
bought bags
made extra money on the side spent it
all oh the tax man
and i wasn't prepared [ __ ] hell well
i mean that's
a great advert for manchester united
university maybe it was just me
maybe i was just like young and dumb but
like it helped me from a career
perspective but
a lot of the financial courses out there
don't
help people be better themselves of
money and that's psychology point
because
money isn't such an emotional thing
especially as like an immigrant yeah oh
yeah
exactly yeah when you come and you grew
up on a councillor state right growing
up in a council state getting money
yeah dangerous concoction for getting a
lamborghini or [ __ ] up with some
chanel bag or some [ __ ] exactly
but like i grew up on the council estate
and then my mom bought her council house
rights for 17 grand sold that house for
250 grand
used that money to buy it to build a
property empire
and that's how she ended up retiring so
when i was in manchester
i was actually my mom bought like four
houses in manchester so i was doing
property management while being a
student
so i was still like running businessy
stuff like as a student
so even though i had that came from the
council background
i'd seen kind of like how hustle and
money could kind of be made and that
i didn't have to be broke forever if i
was kind of smart about it
your mom sounds like all right beast
she's wild she bought four houses while
you're in manchester
yeah no how many no three oh well yeah
so different yeah yeah but they were
and i can't swear they're like right can
i swear of course you can swim
she was just in it for the flip oh yeah
exactly yeah so you start at some point
blogging while at university and
why did you turn to blogging why why was
that a
compelling path blogging or vlogging
i kind of went into it because i kind of
had like a
friendship fallout and i became a bit of
a loner like i didn't have a big social
group
like people would go out without me and
i would live with a group of girls
and they'd all go out together and i'd
be like left at home by myself
so i i found like online communities
so i was part of different forums before
reddit was read it
before youtube existed there were like
forums where girls would talk to each
other about beauty and makeup
and i'd spend hours like writing to
these girls across the world
and sending them pictures and they're
used to before instagram there was [ __ ]
key there's all these platforms
where we were communicating and then um
some of the girls would send videos to
each other of like
their new hair and their new makeup like
so random
and then youtube had just launched it's
like this is a great way to send videos
to each other
and so i kind of got sucked up in
communi
communicating with all the people that i
met online
because my real life wasn't that great
and i guess when you started in youtube
you never
never thought it was anything more than
a no it wasn't a thing
at the time of me like watching youtube
and
kind of creating on the platform there
wasn't actually that many people on
there
um and so like little artists could go
viral and there'd be
like there's a song chocolate rain i
don't know if you guys remember what i
remember with the the black guy with the
hat yeah
like yeah yeah that was like
mind-blowingly amazing and then what
there was michelle phan
she was like the main beauty girl that
was really like
killing it so it was such a small little
ecosystem that
wasn't a business but it was genuinely
about like
connecting and talking to other people
online why did you do so well in
hindsight
on youtube honestly length of time
like i was just doing it for a really
long time and i was very
transparent like i was so transparent i
was putting a lot of information out
there
um i wasn't that strategic with it but i
loved
talking to people online like they were
literally my friends
and i used it a bit like a online diary
in a way
very earlier on um but it wasn't like a
full-time
thing i was like interning and working
um but i think eventually i got really
strategic about it
and that's when i saw like more growth
or
huge growth um you were saying that you
know you first started
um like the online forums and stuff at a
time when you'd like falling out with
your flatmates
and um i guess from what it sounds like
youtube was giving you that sense of
like community i guess and
that you weren't getting in the real
world fact yes
definitely i didn't have like a huge
social life
after a while um after the fallout and
i had so much solace with just this
online community
i never felt lonely because i could log
in and there'd be someone on there and i
could read
all the forum updates and talk to the
girls who are into the things that i was
into
they were all over the world it was just
really nice to like have friends
you referred to the fallout as if it was
a really pivotal moment in your life
it was it wasn't uh it wasn't that
pivotal but it's quite hard when you're
at uni and like
your friends are off doing stuff and
like meeting people and then you're you
don't have anything to do
or they they're not talking to you it
feels like a big thing
in in real life it's really not a big
thing like but at the time it was like
i'm so lonely
i'll go online okay yeah wow good thing
you did
what a journey and you say consistency
you point at consistency as being the
real
factor to your success but consistency
must come from
you know enjoying it because there'll be
a lot of people listening to this
thinking i want to be a youtuber i mean
everybody seems to want to be a youtuber
yeah but the insanity to do it as long
as you did without
the um guarantee
of money must have come from somewhere
there was no guarantee of money it was a
hobby like if you're a painter
you like painting at the weekend you're
gonna paint anyway
whether someone pays you for your art or
not you just enjoy doing it
so i just enjoyed making videos
that other girls watch and i could talk
to the other girls so
i didn't get paid for like four years
but i was always uploading every weekend
it was my hobby like it wasn't this is
going to be my new job
which is why i even struggle with it now
and that i really
want to enjoy it in the same way that i
always enjoyed it
and do i need to look for a new hobby
and is now youtube my job like
oh i find it really hard to kind of
balance the fact that
this thing that was my my escape is kind
of like my job now
there's we i was talking to one of the
guests on the podcast a couple of weeks
ago about um
this study where when someone gets paid
to do a task they used to love doing
they lose motivation for it and it's
just mental they they do the study where
they give people this game
people enjoy doing the game they then
say we're going to ask you to do the
game again but this time you're going to
get paid
the other group don't get paid and the
group that got paid to do the thing they
just enjoyed doing
lose motivation doesn't it make a lot of
sense you two stopped paying me
i like those checks um that is insane
it's you lose internal motivation when
it becomes
when when some of the um reason for
doing it becomes
extrinsic monetary so and this is a
you know it's a wise oh my gosh it's
tough isn't it
it's really tough because people are
like oh my god like what privileged
conversation
it's not because like say imagine
someone's like a
a dart player or something right but
eventually once they get into the
competitive sports of
darts maybe it becomes a bit more
stressful maybe they don't enjoy it as
much maybe
the the the challenge of doing it is now
i've got to perform for my management
and the the
crew or whatever there's a dark crew
i just made that up but that becomes
like i don't know
more pressure than the person who just
wanted to play darts on the saturday
night would feel can you feel that
no no but the reason being is that
i'm i try to frame what i do as
i've accepted that i have a huge desire
to create
stuff right that's it so as long as i
focus on
this process is creation this process is
creation
i'll be fine and that might mean saying
no to work
and no to sponsorships for a season so i
can at least
feel that creation because it i'm very
much like
how do i feel about this which is kind
of bad but
also it's allowed me to do what i'm
doing feels like a good long-term
strategy
yeah right because if you're not asking
that question in the short term how do i
feel about this
so many people in fact i think the guest
that just sat in that chair last
um you end up gradually becoming someone
you never intended to be and ending up
someone you never intended to go
so that constant asking of that question
how do i feel about this today
which as you alluded to means turning
down money sometimes
but you know thinking longer term about
what you're doing and why you're doing
it i think is so critical
so critically important you know the
thing that had the biggest positive
impact on me
sticking to the gym has been this change
in mindset and i've talked about this
extensively on this podcast about how i
used to view
my goals in the gym as being super
superficial and attached to a season
to summer looking good for summer and
that the shift came in me
when i started asking myself this
question and i started viewing life as
one season
so i'd say to myself if if life is to be
one season then what can i do
sustainably
over the next 50 years what are the
healthy habits that i could maintain
and that moves you from a place of
intensity to consistency
and one of the things that has really
helped me get in great shape
is the ready to drink cures in the
bottles as you'll know i've had them for
three to four years i've had two today
alone but also huel's brand new protein
product
i've completely finished the salted
caramel one and i'm now
starting my journey with the banana
milkshake and it just tastes amazing
and the crazy thing is it's 105 calories
some people historically you know when
we
think about protein shakes we look at
the calorie number when we see 300
calories
it's 105 calories you get all of your
vitamins and minerals
and it's 20 grams of protein for me this
might be the best product that you would
have ever created
and in terms of the results well they
speak for themselves
you know we've got two guests that have
come to watch this podcast today and
sophia i said sophia you know she's
she's followed you for some time i said
sophia if you could ask patricia any
question what would it be she said to me
um how did she find the confidence to
make the leap from that sort of
corporate career
to going full time with this thing
called youtube
so for me my confidence came from an
excel spreadsheet
so i am not a risk taker i'm
more of a steady and stable person but i
did a bit of maths
i did a bit of a projection i looked at
what my
long-term potential earnings
and lifestyle would look like if i
stayed in the banking industry
and then i looked at what my numbers
were looking like
you know if i stayed as a creator where
could i take it
and even at that time i had no clue i
could get to where i am
today but the numbers looked healthy
enough so i was like
okay i'll take the leap even if i do it
for two years
it could be okay um and i didn't just
jump out i kind of um took a
toe dip in and i quit my job but then i
took another job that was part time
so i could make content and have a job
as well
and you call your mum you say quit my
job i didn't tell her i didn't tell my
mom i didn't tell
anybody what you've quit your big
banking job oh
hell no i could never do that so
i knew my parents would be worried and
scared should we tell them now
no no no no so mom i left my job
they barely know what i do right now
they're like i do this thing on the
internet they're like oh wow
it's fine yeah yeah so my mom but yeah
so you made that you took that leap
into youtube um was there a moment where
you think [ __ ] how this is
this is moving this is
or was it just one step at a time slow
and steady yeah
slow and steady i was making i'd been
making content for seven years
and then i got to a million subscribers
so i didn't have any of those
really viral moments and i saw lots of
people
kind of steamroll ahead of me like go
viral
they were part of these groups and these
crews and you know there was a time that
there was a thing called the brick pack
they were all there
and i was just like in the corner by
myself like plodding along
and then inevitably like my my time
came and it took again that seven years
to one million
and then one more year to another
million and a half
and i then had my own viral moment off
the back of myself
and um but i never kind of took the step
back to be like oh you've made it
because i never feel like i've made it
not even now not yet
a lot of people might be surprised by
that um
maybe but it depends on someone's
personal definition of making it right
and what's yours
domination
what is mine um it's not just being
popular on social media that's not my
complete definition of success right i
think for me it's like
creating things that i want to create
when i want to create them
and monetizing them and bringing value
so
if i say my overall thing that's it what
that looks like i don't know just yet
and you don't think you're there yet you
don't think you're creating things that
you really
oh i'm doing it i'm doing it but i don't
think i've had like one
big thing yeah does anyone have one big
thing though
i don't know i think that i you know i
think if you'd gone back and asked
patricia when she was at mmu
what her making it look like you would
have said you know hundred thousand
followers
on my
yeah so maybe the goal post is just
moving off into the future
maybe that's maybe that speaks to what
life is it's just that journey as
opposed to that destination right so
yeah yeah and influencers being an
influencer
talk to me about that when i say it you
know what do you think about
the lifestyle the stigmas etc etc
so when people say influence i think
there's a little cringe when they say it
but i think this concept of being
influential
is has always been around but it's
always been around with the hands of
the upper echelon of people only certain
people are
are picked by certain industries to be
influential
but what i love is like now there's this
democratization
people can choose who they want to be
influenced by
and how i got in my position is because
people liked me
they decided that actually i want to
hear what patricia has to say i want to
see what she's buying i want to see what
she likes
so i think it's a really powerful tool
we've all been influenced the question
is like
we want to choose who those influences
are
it's a it's a it's a big i guess
responsibility to some
because i know for a fact that every
time something happens in the world
you get a dm patricia i thought you were
with us
why aren't you doing 55 instagram posts
about
palestine or kenya or india or oxygen in
the fires in australia i thought you
were one of it's a lot it's a lot
that's a lot bearing in mind that my
forte
is makeup and clothing and and maybe
financed you know to an extent
i feel
there is pressure for influencers to
speak up on every topic
all the time but we are not credible
sources
who know everything we just don't and i
think it's really important for us to
say
we're ignorant on a matter and we're
learning but kind of speaking up on
stuff that you know nothing about is
very very
stupid dangerous yeah yeah and stupid
yeah um
and also what is really scary is that if
you don't think the same way that
everybody else thinks
you're in trouble what if you have an
alternative
perspective you're not allowed to have
an alternative perspective
if you ask of peace whether or not it's
you know in the middle east specifically
or for on a certain matter oh no way
because the world wants to keep
everything burning but
like personally i'm like can can this
just chill
like not just that situation
specifically but a lot of situations i'm
like
i just wish it wasn't happening is that
your approach to it you think generally
if i don't have a
a proper well-rounded view
because it's all well people like
because i get the same this is how i
know you'd get the same
people message me and say steve speak on
this issue or black lives matter or
whatever
um while i'm still processing it and
what you're right what they're actually
saying is
share my opinion to your followers on
this issue
and they're trying to try and like guilt
trip me into it like
yeah you know especially when it's when
it's a group of people that i can relate
to
just viscerally so like my skin color
yeah yeah i'm expected to be
a you know the spokesman of all black
people yeah
oh me too as well yeah yeah it's a lot
of yeah a lot of um
nastiness what what else do you think is
um unappreciated about being an
influencer you've obviously got a big
platform
the other thing i was going to say right
this is what i was just thinking as
we're talking
um the other day i thought and i've been
working out for a year and a half now i
always like talking about this
love it um and grace who sat behind that
curtain over there
i sent her a photo i'm going to post
like a transformation picture
okay like the before and after and me
and grace had a conversation because
if i was a female and i'd posted that
i would have got [ __ ] ripped to
pieces
right i would have been told i was toxic
irresponsible body image
yeah i posted it fine yeah 100 of people
like
send us your plan like whatever yeah
yeah and it really made me reflect on
how
tough it is to be a woman on social
media with a big audience it's like
the standard of perfection in terms of
your like morals
what you're posting how you're posting
what you're saying is a high bar to
reach
yeah whereas i'm not held to that
standard as a guy okay
yeah yeah i'm not surprised
but there's gonna be different standards
you're held by so
with the women like
us there's a lot of pressure around our
appearance
or if we're mothers how we mother or
what we're wearing i mean it's so random
but i'm sure there's
definitely things that men are going to
expect from you
that that i can't believe you did this
or something even relates to success
it's like i can come on and i could come
on this podcast yeah
and say that i the reason i'm successful
is because of me
and i can talk about my big old
ambitions and i'm gonna
when a woman does it it's like you know
what i mean it just seems like there's
just a double
a total double standard the fact that i
can post me being kind of slightly
overweight in that shape
and then like nine 19 pack like
do you know what i mean i saw many
videos you said seven abs or whatever
like seven abs whatever
and the comments are like whoo but i
know if
if um if a woman did the same thing it
would be like this is irresponsible what
are you saying fat shame
why is that i mean because
like men and women are fundamentally
different so
presuming that your audience is like
probably say
sixty percent to seventy percent male 1
eighty percent women
eighty percent with uh
i think women judge men by different
standards so what you'll see
oh let's talk about this what you'll
actually see
in the world of beauty and women's
fashion
and um industries that are
predominantly consumed by women men are
always
at the forefront so the biggest
influences
in the beauty industry are five men men
who wear makeup
right and that's yeah so men who wear
makeup
are more popular than or let's say three
men who wear makeup
can be bigger and get to bigger
stratospheres
than any women could um the fashion
industry
and fashion brands all of them the
majority of them
are owned by men and ran by men or
creative directors are men
not women not women there aren't a lot
of brands that are run and owned by
women
and i just think this is something to do
with biology
sociology the way in which kind of women
interact with
men is different to how we interact with
each other i wish it was different
but i've i've just noticed this like a
lot
and and the other point which i kind of
alluded to there as well as on on this
topic of gender disparities i guess is
it like just
discrediting success yeah do people
discredit your success
do you know what not so much and i think
also because i'm a black woman
people are so happy to see me do well
because they feel like it's rare and so
i think i'm afforded
a bit more luxury to be a bit more like
aggressive about
you know i'm pushing i'm moving hard
whether you like it or not that's the
nigerian in me coming out
and culturally i think um i'm allowed to
celebrate that a lot more because
brits i don't think like to celebrate
people doing too well or
being too much um so i can get away with
it a little bit more
um but i know like
there is a little it can be tension when
i talk about my numbers too much
and i'll definitely get the messages of
this is
not what you should be talking about you
shouldn't talk about how much you earn
it's a bit rude
imagine a guy doing it though oh
go one what show us the lamborghini
again do you know what i mean it's like
that's all guys do
yeah that's how they build their status
is like i mean
just that's what that's how it works
have you put your lamborghini on no no i
don't have a lamborghini
but no but i can openly talk about how
much money i've i've
generated in my companies and no one's
ever going to say oh that's so just
tasteful they clap
and but when women do it they people do
go oh god she's not that's not good
taste is it yeah
and that again is a huge like ben
francis he talks about he's built a one
point
something billion dollar company
everyone's like amazing yeah you know
they can show men can show the nice
things the cars the houses whatever and
it's all but
the minute grace beverly does a house
tour you can't do it yeah
i have a video called like how i made a
million
on youtube right and um
it's firstly it's got like over almost a
million views on it
and um but the comments were so kind of
crazy people are like i can't believe
you're sharing this
we're really excited but um also
like um you should be putting this out
there and what i actually did is there's
no
way i could actually share my actual
numbers
because i think people would judge me
negatively
and like fall over be like what the hell
how is it possible and like almost want
to stop the bag
if that makes any sense like they don't
people don't like to see women doing
two big numbers you gotta still be
humble as a woman
how do you respond to that though how do
you how does that impact the choices you
make and does it impact
the choices you make isn't that sad
though that yeah it really does
so i've moved away from like putting out
my numbers
i'm not gonna use using my numbers as a
strategy or
showing my things too much as a strategy
i also
bought a couple of properties and you
know i really want
to share with people about financial
empowerment and
properties and making money but like i
can see that almost like a
a sour taste sometimes in people's
mouths so i show a bit less of it i i'm
not going to show you the new house that
i bought
or or something else i'm not going to
show it as much and
i've tried to make more relatable
content
and a lot of us have to be relatable and
remain
humble to still be considered um
a good influencer just don't show what
you have
are you happy with that though are you
happy to go along with that and to to do
what
um because when we spoke earlier about
what your goal is it's to make stuff
that like really matters to you and that
sounds like it's driven by like
my terms you know what i care about in
my way
and not allowing the audience to dictate
what you create that sounded like your
north star
and this being a good influence but it
doesn't sound like it's gonna make you
very happy
yeah i think it's all about being
strategic though right
so like if um
eventually showing lots of glamorous
stuff
is gonna impact growth it would be silly
for me to keep doing it right
and again that's not my personal
strategy anyway i'll be honest with you
i don't want to be like
look at my new lamborghini look at my
new house that's not who i am as a
person
is a bit cringe for me and it's not part
of my strategy but
um i do want to remain authentic but i
understand that
showing too much of my success um
doesn't always sit well for people
and i'm happy to like remove that aspect
if that makes people more comfortable
and i think that's because i'm a woman
like i want people to feel comfortable
um and you know you're you start this
platform called the break
yeah that was it when i say when i say
that there's a big smile on your face
yeah that's like my like my passion
project
turned like great potential business
opportunity
and i think for me that's like where i
decided to
start talking about these things and
we're just we're talking about this now
that people don't talk about money women
don't talk about money
on that platform i am unapologetic
and that's what i shared about the
making a million in a year or making a
million over a lifetime and
showing how i budget my salary and
showing you how i bought a house in 10
minutes
i put that all on there because i feel
like
you know over there is where i'm going
to talk about this stuff so if you like
it
is there if you don't like it let's go
put on makeup on my other channel
and um it's been just insane to see how
it's grown
and how much there's a huge demand for
this type of
content within this demographic
it was what was missing when you started
out from what you said earlier
exactly and that's why i created it
because you were buying all those bags
and
being a bit reckless and no one told you
so you exactly and the tax man came
knocking at my door and i got
fined and i was like nobody needs to do
this this is how you incorporate this is
how you
get your pension sorted out this is how
you can buy a property for your business
and i was just literally doing all the
stuff that i kind of learned from my
accountant
and from the financial mistakes that
i've made i really wanted to just say
here you go here's this information use
this make it
be valuable to you to help you on your
journey do you know in black culture
we um growing up you know i was watching
50 cent and
all this stuff and he is a bad financial
advisor
because am i can you get some advice
from 50 cent though
[ __ ] every black young black man and
what he told me about bottles and
lamborghinis and stuff
it really hurt me when i was 21 and i
finally got money and i went to the club
and i was getting five bottles of don
perry on please
and i blew a lot of cash and i just wish
those those role models like the rappers
that i followed when i was younger
i wish they told me about credit scores
you know what i mean i wish
but that's not it's not sexy right it's
not glamorous it's not fun
like i have a video on pensions like
40401ks and
whether or not you should be making a
contribution to your sip right
that is not oh this is glamorous no one
wants to hear that
but there are going to be a few who do
take it and use it
i wish we could dress up like credit
scores like
give it lipstick give it a lamborghini
um but we haven't mastered that yet
maybe i'll do that later
but they don't want people to know the
truth
i don't think anybody wants people to
really know the truth about finances
right it's not beneficial it's not
beneficial to government it's not
beneficial to corporations
it's not beneficial to banks and lenders
who actually
want people to be inept
in this area so they can make financial
mistakes and then give them more money
so like that's the reality of it like
rich people aren't actually struggling
financially
it's actually everyone else on the maybe
lower end of the spectrum
who don't have this information but this
information
will transform their lives i guess
that's why they call it financial
freedom
there we go yeah and you said this
started as a passion project and now
it's turned into a potential business
opportunity
exactly talk to me about that and where
is it going ah this is this is a lot
so where's it going so we really want to
build out like a web platform which has
content but also
tools that people can use so one of the
things that i created was a simple
budgeting
like template and like literally in like
two weeks we had like 20 000 people
download
an excel spreadsheet on how to manage
their day-to-day income
so clearly there's more that we can do
here
we then launch a planner as well that
just sold out in like
a day or two and then we're launching
more of these so
for in the long run i'd like to provide
more financial tools and resources
that people could use to help them with
managing their everyday
finances the dream is like an app but
that takes time
to like happen but like we've got the
designs and
we're doing some testing now to really
see how we can like build that out
further
of all the work you're doing across all
of these different projects and i'm sure
there's many many more that we won't
even talk about today
is this the thing you're most excited
about
and it's like choosing your choosing
your favorite child but
i would say it's something i'm really
excited about because
it's so valuable so i'm very excited
about it and i think it's a new
challenge
so as an influencer like i work for
brands
i make amazing content for them i get
nice things but now
this is my chance to kind of be a brand
and create
value more so so it's really like a new
challenge for me that i'm excited to
kind of
get into and you when you're saying we
you know
we've made an excel document who is we
so actually excel
document i made but i do have like my
husband who's been really supportive and
like helping me build that out
and then i've like recruited a ceo to
like help me
think about scaling this out but um i've
had
other team members here and there
freelancers here and there but i know
inevitably that scaling is something i'm
gonna have to
be willing to do and that's hard
for myself to do yeah
your husband my husband michael michael
can i call him mike you can call him
mike i can
i can see him over there in the corner
of the room follow me around
what's it like working with mike so
oh that's a really good question so
working with mike
you know what michael's been like with
me for every step of my journey as a
creator
and he's always worked a full-time job
and then
he inevitably went even to more of a
freelance role
so that i could use him when i needed
him so he will work as a contractor and
i'm like mike i need your help
quit your job come and help me and so
throughout my entire journey he's been
there to do that
however working with your significant
other
can be real difficult um and there are
times when we're like
let's not do this go back to your job
make something happen go back
contracting
and then when we're like oh we're cool
come back again
so it's what's important for us is
actually to establish
how we communicate with each other and
boundaries like when we're working
together we actually don't work in the
same environment
so he'll work in an office and i'll work
somewhere else because if you work in
the same room at the same time
it's not pretty we're gonna send a
microphone over to mike in the audience
it's not pretty yeah because i think
when you're in like
boss mode like you can be quite direct
like i'm very like this doesn't look
good i don't like this
can we change this how how do we do this
better this is wrong right
and i think there are when it's with
your partner
they're going to take that personally
over say someone else who is
you know just working with you and i
haven't developed my managerial skills
to be
great when it comes to you know my
interpersonal skills just yet
so and i think when you're working with
a loved one as well
you you feel like you want to be more
direct like they should know
just you should know this come on like
but
he doesn't always know and he can't read
my mind and he's a man so
there's there's differences there um so
that's when it gets a bit difficult when
we're together
and how do you how do you balance like
leaving work at work
and not bringing that home with you
because one thing i came to learn was
that
the steve bartlett that succeeds in a
professional environment that is direct
that is it's very clear and
uncompromising it's not the same steve
bartlett that is required to
compromise and oh you want to go for a
walk in the park for no reason
how do you be two different people in
order to achieve two completely
different objectives
and how do you do that also when you're
you live and work in the house
right the same house because that's
something that we deal with i think it's
again about setting these boundaries
like physically
so michael won't really work in a house
even if he's working on
my projects and i'll try and work from
an office as well as much as possible
um and then it's the case of like
switching off it's hard man it's really
hard
i think as a creator as a social media
creator like you're always on
i haven't mastered that yet but we have
kids so
the good thing about kids is that they
force us to
like give them love and give them
attention so we have to switch off and
sort the kids out and give them a bath
and give them dinner
so we'll always kind of i don't know
switch brains
because of that oh there's a really good
point i never actually thought about
the fact that kids would actually force
some kind of balance into your life they
do which is
you know yes amazing and you guys have
been together a long time
a long time yeah we've been together for
14
14 years yeah and married for like
nine years i think yeah nine years yeah
i always i always think because because
um because of my own experiences of
being pretty useless at relationships
um entrepreneurs and especially i mean
creators that's a different bag because
you say you're always on they're quite
difficult to date
yes yeah yeah and i think as well
and i'm probably gonna get in [ __ ]
there's a troll famous but i don't
really care i'm gonna die anyway
um i think from entrepreneurs from other
cultures
who have come up from another background
and another another mother can be even
more
tricky to date yes you spoke to your
mother you used the word
yeah we'll say passionate yeah yeah yeah
yeah
does that really really yeah so
obviously michael's like
a englishman from from manchester right
and like we are very culturally
very different and i think but it's so
interesting i think if i wasn't with
michael i'd be very single and very
lonely
like i've accepted that i don't know if
anybody else would like actually handle
me
if that makes any sense i think it takes
a certain kind of person
to be with an entrepreneurial person let
alone an entrepreneurial nigerian woman
like that's like so many different
layers there
and yeah yeah he's like a magician to be
able to handle that
and we're like polar opposite people i'm
very
like emotional and like let's do this
now and he's very
logical steady stable and i think that
actually is the balance that i've needed
like
and i think we're meant to be together
to like
i don't know ying and yang it's great
you said he followed you here today but
i heard you actually had a cyber stalker
oh yeah it's not yeah it's not mike it
wasn't like i found it it was actually
his account
disturbing me yeah no i did i had a
stalker for like three years
um and it was someone who would like
just
message me on all my platforms
constantly send emails
message family members really weird
and nowadays i can't even remember like
what their
what their issue was i don't think they
even had one they were just
obsessive me and obsessive like my
relationship
to an extent because i used to put vlogs
out and i used to have like
content with me and my husband and i
stopped like actually it sounds so bad
but i think
it was enough to tell me i'm not going
to put myself out there
in that way why
i i think it takes an emotional
toll having a stalker because you're
worried like when you log in
am i going to see their messages what
are they going to do today what are they
going to say today
are they going to dox me so they found
out my parents name and address
and say your mom's this name and she
lives here
so like those things and obviously it
was like psychological warfare
um but it was yeah it was more
psychological
but like when i was thinking about it i
kept thinking it's because i put myself
out there too much this is why they're
targeting me and i think inevitably it
made me want to
retreat in certain aspects do you still
think that was the case
no i think that was one of my triggers
but i think inevitably i was like
putting yourself out there
too much from a personal perspective um
wasn't something i wanted to do like i
used to show
like i showed our wedding i showed me
giving birth
i've shown i put a lot out there okay
link in the bio
looking via my best story
um and like the platforms love it when
you put yourself out there a lot
but inevitably it does take a toll on
you as a person
and i i just said we're going to stop
this i don't want to be that person
i actually care more about my real life
than putting
a version of my real life online i tend
to think when you're reaching that many
people
just probabilistically just by numbers
you're gonna reach
at least 10 artists yeah okay just like
do you know what i mean regardless it
just happens yeah
yeah and you're blocking this person i'm
guessing every time they pop up and then
they're making a new account
they're making hundreds of accounts
they're messaging other people so what
would happen is that when i would
message someone online
they would like be in in the thread or
they'll be watching everything i was
doing so
i'd have to tell people i'm really sorry
i've got a stalker
like if you got that message it's from
it's from a stalker
that like message brand sometimes it was
just really weird behavior
and at some point it stopped it vanished
or yeah it
reduced it reduced i'd say and then it
inevitably like
disappeared i kind of forgot about it to
be honest after a while
but i learned how to like listen to
their speech pattern
so even if they would create new
profiles i always knew it was them
based on the things that they would say
and how they would say it
so they'll try to hide that it was them
but it's like it's clearly you
like and there's even like online forums
where people
like moan about online creators and she
would like
she or he would go into the forums
and be like talking about me so i would
stalk my stalker
right so i knew it was them and then
other people in the forum would be like
your patricia stalker that they would
know it was the stalker
so yeah anyway wow what a ride
that made you feel unsafe at any point
there was nothing where it was like we
know your home address we're gonna i'm
gonna come there
there was some of that oh really so
there was some of so i did a meet and
greet an event
and then they messaged me he's like haha
i was at your meet and greet
you didn't even know who i was you
didn't see me you look so terrible in
person
next time i'm gonna do something right
so i remember feeling
so anxious and i would i vlogged it and
i remember like looking through the
footage and i was like
who could it be who could it be it's
like racking my brain it's like which
one is it which one is it
and i think it made me a bit paranoid
like sure a season
but i was never scared because i'm from
south london
i'm not scared come to my house
we'll see
quick one i talk about fiverr.com a lot
on this podcast but i think the perfect
sort of illustration of the power of
fiverr
was actually illustrated a few weeks ago
when jack who is the director
and producer of this podcast was away
and so we had to find someone to step in
to um edit
the episode with dr alex
and so we turned to fiverr and that
whole episode which you would have seen
on youtube was edited
by a young guy who we found on fiverr
and for me that's the perfect
illustration of the diversity
the cost effectiveness but also the sort
of bandwidth that you can achieve
on short notice by using fiverr.com and
if you haven't used fiverr there's such
a diverse array of services on the
website delivered by freelancers
everything from graphic design to
building websites to getting subtitles
done to
podcasts anything check it out go to
fiverr.com that's with two hours
slash ceo so what's what's next for you
then in your in your life as you look
forward
you know i'm not talking about goals i'm
just saying the
sort of macro the overall feeling you
want from your life and where you want
to be
i think it's being open to more
challenges that are different
to what i'm used to i have been making
content
and creating by myself for myself four
brands for so long for like 10 years
and i i although i think i'm a brave
person i feel like i've got very
comfortable
so i want to set myself out on
challenges
that are completely outside of my
comfort zone
maybe do something that
you know is unexpected for me unexpected
for me as a creator
influencers don't do this or influences
of your size don't do this or
this kind of thing and i really want to
work on like creating more products and
really building out a brand and not
necessarily being
the face of everything why we're not the
face of everything
so i actually realized though i'm in the
public eye
to an extent like i don't really like
being famous
i don't really want to be a personality
i don't want things to be about me
and i don't know why i put myself out
there if i didn't want that
but i think fundamentally i'm happy to
slink into the background
yeah i think there are other people who
want it more like
i don't enjoy being
famous as in not that i don't enjoy but
i think there are
people who like really want to be famous
right and there are people who just want
to do what they do
and do it well and like not just have
their own normal friends
do that their own normal things and get
on with life like i get on the train
every day
and i i go on the underground and some
people like you get on the underground
i'm like yes it's quicker
but i don't want to ever be in a place
where i can't get on the underground
people are stopping you saying hi
patricia i can have yeah pitch and
you're like no kovid no i always say
no i was like i'm always friendly i
guess you can use that
fame for things that you do care about
there right like
i like that you're right you know what i
mean it's like double
double-edged sword it costs something
but it gives creates an opportunity for
something
in a way oh yeah wow you just
you just yeah you just told me off there
in a good way
yeah that's kind of what i can the
battle i'm having at the moment because
obviously
just on dragon's den yeah exactly and
that's going to be all over the tv and
stuff and people are going to start
coming up to me and pitching me their
business ideas in the street which i
don't want to [ __ ] yeah
well i have an idea for you no but you
know what i mean like you're going to
get
because i went out with peter jones for
like dinner yeah yeah and
he goes i'm just going to pop to the
toilet yeah and like he takes
three steps and a guy stops him hi peter
i know i knew you were here
pitches him the idea the percentage asks
and i'm just looking at people thinking
that's going to be my [ __ ] life
but what so what's the upside what's the
why am i doing this why have i created
why have i put myself out there and i
think okay all the other upsides are
that it's going to allow me to
build things that are more in line with
the things i care about it gives you a
platform an audience well you know
yeah no you're right you're right and i
and i'm
battling with the fact that there's
clearly a reason why i'm
i'm here or why i've got this audience
and why i people connect with me right
and actually maybe it's a good thing
that i have no huge desires to be famous
um so i'm gonna have to work out how to
deal with
that attention in a way um better
and not just think about slinking into
the background because that's how you
feel
slinking into the background i wanna i
wanna be low-key
like i want to make my videos and it
sounds crazy and no one really watched
them
well i like i like the idea of when
things are small
because i've been very viral like so i
was really bad i was getting like 8
million views a video
13 million views a video and at the time
i was like oh this is quite this is a
lot for me
to like handle because people are like
messaging me all the time like patricia
and i'd be like hey guys hey um so it's
not that i want to slink into the
background
i think i just need to be more
comfortable with recognizing that you
know i'm here i'm doing it
um but still keep that normality that's
really important for me
and what have you learned over the in
terms as it relates to if you because
i'm thinking now about you've got an
entrepreneur over there in the corner
sophia
and she's she's starting a meal prep
business she's also working in the city
in finance
okay so it's very coincidental that
she's
she happens to be here today if you were
speaking to someone like sophia and you
were just giving her a bit of advice on
how to um become
as successful in what you do as you have
been what are those
underlying principles where you say that
really is the thing there's no quick
route
but that thing there is the thing
so i think the first thing is leaning
into your like authentic tone
like what is the thing that makes you
or your brand yours and not running away
from that and not trying to be
something else it's like learning to not
be scared of yourself this is what we
are this is who i am
this is it right and then consistently
putting that
out all the time so that people connect
with that they either connect or they
don't but you only want those who are
going to connect with that
true version of yourself or your brand
and then it's of course you know you're
going to jump on trends
or or things that are
vital so you can get traction that's
what i did i would jump onto viral
trends
but do it in my own tone of voice um
and you know it's the consistency
continue i've never done this before but
i want to ask mike a question if i can
you can answer one quick question he's
famous mike i saw you on her instagram
actually with the with the baby father
today um
i wanted to ask you from your
perspective why do you think patricia
has been so
successful in what she's done well i
reckon for a number of reasons
partly i think it's her personality
personally because she does that
knowledge
so patricia christian doesn't
acknowledge a lot of good things about
herself
she's definitely 100 her biggest critic
she
brings a lot of energy and passion and
enthusiasm and stuff
so when you watch her you feel good or
you feel happy or you feel interested or
inspired
but something that she doesn't really
acknowledge but i think that's a part of
it i do think there's certain
fundamental
like i suppose numerical things like
consistency
and sticking with it over time and you
know all those types of
factses that you can look at from a
numbers perspective that help
so definitely doing that and staying
with it and doing you know your three
uploads a week and your regular posts
and all those sort of things that help
but there's a lot of people that do that
and don't have the same level of success
right
so that's why you have to look at what's
the differentiating factors
so i think there's that i think there's
an element of
um her kind of openness and honesty and
her
also because of i think partly because
she's done it a long time
she's very natural and authentic
so you don't feel like you're watching
someone who's performing
you feel like you're watching someone
who is
genuinely you know giving who they are
to you
and that's rare right so i asked mike
there what you know what his
he thought the cause of factors behind
your success where he pointed at
personality
you being vulnerable and you being
authentic and
um yeah i mean that's
that's kind of rare online with the
world we live in with perfection
filters and don't share the bad [ __ ]
yeah and i think i'm lucky in that i
came up in an
age of making content where it was so
authentic
there was no business behind it and it
was about connection
so i had that training that was my
training gown for being a creator
just just do what you do don't don't
think about it just do what you like
so i i feel lucky that i've got that as
like my
basis as creating um and being an
influencer
well i i can certainly feel that and i
think it comes through in everything you
do especially the stuff you're doing on
the break i've never watched videos
about finance that seemed to be
so entertaining and real and weren't
trying to be like
snotty financial like long word business
[ __ ] advice
yeah so it made it super like inclusive
and um
real and obviously that's what's absent
in that space exactly
is inclusion that's why we both probably
bought bags we shouldn't have bought
don't play on that i definitely should
have bought absolutely so thank you so
much patricia for your time today you're
such an inspiration to so many and
much you know much of the reason for
that in my view is because you're such a
real person
thank you and um and you're willing to
share that realness with everybody
um what you've done is remarkable and
i'm sure this is just the beginning for
you
you look about 23 as well i was like you
literally look 23 but that's that's
part of the upside of the ethnic
background um thank you so much for your
time it's such an honor
thank you for having me it was great to
come on and have a chat thank you
[Music]
um
[Music]
you